our favorite duo jennifer aniston and  reese witherspoon are giving us some  major nostalgia recreating one of their  iconic scenes together this is so good  so any fan of friends will know that the  pair go way back before they became  co-hosts on the morning show reece had a  guest starring role on friends as jill  green the younger sister of rachel which  of course was played by jen that's right  clearly feeling the nostalgia herself  rhys shared a clip of an interview from  2019 where they recreated one of their  most famous scenes from the show take it  away ladies and bye to you have a great  weekend bye  oh that's sweet  is this where you say the line that you  love so much yes this is well we could  say the lines do you remember your line  uh uh you said  i say  you can't have ross can't have  can't have the only thing i can't have  is dairy